-Our next guest is a
Tony-nominated actor
you know from films like
"American Hustle," "Selma,"
and "A Most Violent Year."
He stars in
"The Many Saints of Newark,"
which is in theaters and
available on HBO Max now.
Let's take a look.
-You know I don't like to lean
on you about stuff.
But you can't start
a gambling operation at school.
-I know that...now.
-Don't [ Bleep ] me.
You always knew it.
It's not just the gambling.
It's everything.
The cherry bombs at the YMCA.
Letting the air out of
Mrs. Russo's tires.
-I apologized to her!
-You talk big
about wanting to be on the
football team in high school,
and you're smoking already?
Oh!
You got to have
a better attitude.
With your father gone,
your mother's got
a lot on her plate.
You got to be good.
I don't want to have to
go through this again.
-I try to be good.
-I don't think so.
-Please welcome to the show
Alessandro Nivola.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh.
-That's a very good "oh."
It's a very good.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you so much for being here
and in the studio.
How are you?
-I'm good.
-So this is --
-Thanks for having me.
-It's so exciting to be
back in this world.
It's a prequel.
So, obviously, you weren't
in "The Sopranos," which is
a New Jersey show,
but, you know, for an actor
in New York, especially,
you know, I feel like
when that came out,
that was the show
for actors in New York.
Were you in New York City
at the time?
Were you living here?
-Yeah, yeah.
I was living --
I was living in the Village.
I live in Brooklyn now,
but I was living in --
on Christopher Street, which --
-Alright!
I used to live on Christopher.
-Did you?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You're kidding me?
Where? Between 7th and Bleecker?
That was my --
-Yes. Yep, yeah.
-So you know the block.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, I was living in, like,
a tiny little studio apartment.
There was, you know, my bathtub
was in my living room.
-Uh-huh.
-And across the street was
"Tony n' Tina's Wedding."
You know, the church
where Tony and Tina...
People who are
not from New York,
don't know what
"Tony n' Tina's Wedding" is.
But, it's like, you pay
to be part of, like,
"My Big Fat Italian Wedding"
or whatever.
And you go,
you watch this wedding,
and then they get in a fight
during the wedding,
and they spill out
onto the street.
And they're all, like,
yelling at each other.
And you know,
there's somebody --
a woman saying like,
"Vinny, you worm!
I did it with Mario, Vinny!
I did it with Mario!"
[ Laughter ]
And then, like, underneath me
was a gay leather bar
called Boots & Saddle.
-Uh-huh.
-And those guys --
these big bearded guys were
sitting there at the counter,
just, like, staring out
at "Tony n' Tina's Wedding"
like four times a day,
watching her talk
about doing it with Mario.
[ Laughter ]
That was my life.
-That's New York City
in a nutshell, right there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, you got cast in this.
And obviously,
it was a big deal.
I think people were waiting
for this for a long time.
Your family
must have been excited
that you got this part.
-Yeah.
Well, I -- You know, my --
So, my brother --
I think the day
that I got cast,
I got this text from him
saying like,
"You're not gonna believe this,
but I was watching season 2,
episode something or other,
and it's an episode
where they all went to Italy
to, like, get in touch
with the motherland, you know."
-Yep.
-And, of course,
everyone in Italy, like, thinks
they're a bunch of idiots
or whatever.
Not the reception
that they'd hoped for.
But there's this scene,
and he's watching it,
and James Gandolfini's face
is in close-up.
There it is.
-That's the still, right there.
-So, in the back of the scene
is this sculpture.
-There's a better photo
of the sculpture.
-Yeah, that's this sculpture.
This --
So, my grandfather
made this sculpture.
And he's a sculptor,
and there happened to be
some exhibition
of his stuff in Naples,
where they were filming.
And you know, the guy
who was directing it
liked the look of it,
and he shot the scene.
And there it was,
in the back of the scene.
I called up David Chase
and told him, like, you know,
"My granddad's sculpture
is in your show."
And he was -- he was spooked,
you know.
-Yeah, so, I talked to David
Chase the other day,
and I bet that he was
kind of, like, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-No, this actually
got a rise out of him.
-Oh, that's good.
-He's like --
He gets freaked out
by, sort of, ghosts.
-Okay, that's good to know.
Yeah.
He doesn't seem like a man
who is easily freaked out.
-No, he definitely doesn't
give too much away.
-So, your grandfather was
an artist, as you mentioned,
and friends with another artist.
So, that -- that's
Jackson Pollock.
-Yeah.
-And so your --
So, your grandfather
was friends with him.
-Yeah, so he moved out --
he was living in the Village.
He came from Sardinia
during the war,
and he was living
in Greenwich Village.
And you know, it's part of that
kind of Bohemian scene there.
In fact, he was friends
with De Niro's dad.
-Wow.
-Everybody thinks that De Niro
is, like, the tough guy
from the mean streets.
But he was, like,
the son of an artist
living in the Village
and -- just like my dad.
And then, in the '50s,
my grandfather moved
out to Long Island
to this area where a lot of
artists lived out there.
In fact, so, Pollock
was living there
and de Kooning -- all these guys
who are famous now.
But at the time, they were just,
you know, hanging out together,
getting drunk, and talking
about politics or whatever.
And they used to
give each other art.
And Pollock
gave my grandfather --
Yeah, this is -- okay.
Pollock gave this painting,
right there,
to my grandfather.
And he put it on the wall
in the house --
that's their house --
and he sat there like that
for about a week, I'm told.
And he just, sort of, you know,
stared at it.
And at the end of the week,
he took it down
and he gave it back.
And apparently he said,
[Italian accent] "Jackson,
I cannot keep this painting.
It makes me nervous."
[ Laughter ]
"Whenever the children play
in the room with the painting,
they fight."
[ Normal voice ]
And so he gave it back,
and he took -- you know,
Pollock was like,
"Yeah, you know --"
he took it
and, like, shoved it off
someplace.
-So he just thought it had,
like, a bad energy.
-Well, no, he just, like,
I don't know --
it didn't have the fêng shui
or whatever.
And I then was at MoMA
like a few years ago.
They did a retrospective
on Pollock's work.
[ Chuckles ]
And I saw the painting.
And I'd, like, seen that picture
a million times,
'cause my family had it.
And I was like, "Wait a minute,
that's the picture."
And sure enough,
that was the painting.
And I looked it up,
and it sold at auction
for $25 million.
-You should have --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but the people
who bought it said,
like, their kids fight.
It's not worth it.
[ Laughter ]
-It was a deal with the devil.
-Yeah.
You should have gone up at MoMA
and been like,
"This is so awkward.
That's my painting."
[ Laughter ]
-I wouldn't have had to have
been living across
from "Tony n' Tina's Wedding"
if I had cashed in.
-You did some --
So, you went to Newark,
and you did some --
It was very cool.
You did some research
for the part.
Did you find this picture
of a young -- young Joe Pesci?
Where'd you find this photo?
-Well, there's a museum
in the basement of
Saint Lucy's Church in Newark,
And it's the history of
the whole neighborhood,
of all the Italian part
of Newark.
It's called the First Ward.
And in there are, like, old
pictures that nobody else has.
They're actually -- They're not
like, reproduced pictures.
They're actual photos
on the wall
that people have just given
over the years.
And there's everybody there.
You know, I mean,
Sinatra and all these guys.
But there's
this picture of Pesci.
That's Pesci.
And he was in a band
called the Zaniacs,
which were also known
as the Zani Acts.
-Oh, yeah. There you go.
Now you get it, yeah.
-And they had backup singers
called the Yum Yum girls.
-Yeah.
-There they are.
-And that was him.
-Joe Pesci, you kind of think,
"What would young Joe Pesci
look like?"
And then you're like, "Yeah,
he'd look like that."
[ Laughter ]
-He had some great hair
in those days.
-It's really --
Congrats again on the film.
-Hey, a pleasure. Thank you.
-Thanks so much for spending
time with us.
We really appreciate it.
-Thanks so much.
Great to see you.
-"The Many Saints of Newark"
is in theaters now and
also available on HBO Max.